Alam allayikum.
How are you guys doing? We're here in
Sabib. This is one of the best Somali
restaurants, would you say?
>> Absolutely.
>> Yeah, we know the owner. We've been
>> We've known him for a long time.
>> He's a good man.
>> Good man. And now he's expanded. He's
got one in Actton, I think. Is it
Actton?
>> Actton.
>> And this one here. This is Now, put the
put the camera on the food. This is
called Federation. Yeah. Is that what
it's called?
>> Oh, platter.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah. They've changed the name
now to platter. They're trying to
modernize. But this is like one of the
signature Somali dishes. Now, let me
tell you something about Somali food.
I'm telling you this from my experience.
Okay? I personally think it's one of the
most underrated cuisines, if not the
most underrated cuisine in the entire
world.
It's like there's a party in my mouth
and everyone's invited.
>> Fantastic. What we want to do is react
to a video that Donald Trump has come
viral talking about smiling people. Talk
about that. Mohamad, how are you? Come.
>> Who? Yes. Yes. Show. Show him.
>> This is the owner. He's the owner. We've
had a long-standing relationship for
many many years. You know, this guy here
is a he's one of the what pioneers of
the Somali community. Mashallah. I'm I'm
doing advertisement for your for your
restaurant.
>> Tell us where this place is if they want
to come to this place. Where is
>> in North London?
>> Yeah. N4.
>> Y4. Yeah. There's one in Actton as well,
isn't there?
>> One in Actton as well. One in
>> Actton. I think this one's a little bit
>> It's It's a bit nicer. It's a bit nicer.
Fantastic.
>> But the food is very good though.
>> That's amazing. You've done a fantastic
job. That's what we want more of. So,
let's watch the video and come back and
respond in kind.
>> We're going to go the wrong way if we
keep taking in garbage into our country.
Somalia,
which is barely a country, you know,
they have no they have no anything. They
just run around killing each other. And
they contribute nothing. The welfare is
like 88%.
They contribute nothing.
I don't want them in our country. I'll
be honest with you. Okay. Somebody would
say, "Oh, that's not politically
correct." I don't care. I don't want
them in our country. Their country is no
good for a reason. Their country stinks.
And we don't want them in our country. I
could say that about other countries,
too. I can say it about other countries,
too. We don't want them to hell. We got
to We have to rebuild our country. You
know, our country is at a tipping point.
We could go bad. We're at a tipping
point. I don't know if people mind me
saying that, but I'm saying that uh we
could go one way or the other. And we're
going to go the wrong way if we keep
taking in garbage into our country. Elon
Omar is garbage. She's garbage. Her
friends are garbage. These aren't people
that work. These aren't people that say,
"Let's go. Come on. Let's make this
place great." These are people that do
nothing but complain.
They complain. And from where they came
from, they got nothing. You know, they
came from paradise and they said, "This
isn't paradise." But when they come from
hell
and they complain and do nothing but
we don't want them in our country. Let
them go back to where they came from and
fix it.
>> We saw what Donald Trump said there.
>> Yeah.
>> I eat this food. Tell us what what are
your thoughts on this?
>> Well, a lot of things come to mind. It's
unprecedented for a president to act
like that. Yeah. But I think it's more
for
his audience. You know, I think the MAGA
community split over the Israel issue,
split over the Epson issue. So, it's a
welcome distraction from Donald Trump's
point of view. So, I think that that
plays a significant role in what he's
saying and why he's saying also in line
with what's happening in Europe with
Tommy Robinson and the far right. So it
it does make sense from a political
point of view for him to go that angle.
Yeah, I I think it makes sense. That's
my reading of anyway. What do you think?
>> Look, the Donald Trump is trying to he's
a performer. He's a showman.
>> He he doesn't mind throwing certain
communities under the bus. He doesn't
interact with any Somali people. Yeah.
So he's thinking to himself, how can I
involve race?
>> Yeah.
>> Tell us more about this cuz you were
saying before that, you know, there's
this whole tension between like Somalia
land and Somalia and all that kind of
stuff. Yeah. Now this is not
>> No. But what I was saying is uh
>> the Somali community or the Somali
people are very it's a tribal society
and they there's a lot of divisions
historical issues but thankfully this
had the impact of unifying
the divided factions. Have you seen
that?
>> Yeah I've definitely seen online. Yeah
for sure. So
>> so what kind of things are like what
what are you seeing? What's happening?
I'm seeing people from various
communities, various tribes responding
in a certain way. They're they're pretty
much singing from the same h him she can
say. You get
>> this is a tradition, isn't it?
>> Yeah. Absolutely.
>> Eat the rice
>> and eat the banana.
>> Yeah.
>> And I'll be honest, I'm only doing this
for the cameras. I would never do this.
>> I usually eat bananas different
>> to when I eat the rice.
>> You got to eat with the rice though in
it. Do Do you have the banana?
>> Yeah, I do. Yeah. Is it a thing you do?
>> Yeah, absolutely.
>> Okay.
>> It's a very It's a common thing. Yeah.
>> Okay. Not a problem. So, you were
saying, sorry, I was cutting you off.
>> Yeah. So, I said they had the
from the Somali community point of view,
it's kind of united
>> uh the community a bit. So, I think in
many ways had positive impact.
>> Yeah.
Trump
>> he's actually lower down now improv
rating.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> He's trying to energize his base.
>> Absolutely.
>> He's trying to get through to the white
nationalists.
>> Yeah.
>> That's his base anyway.
>> And then what happened with the whole
the Israel saga cuz MAGA make America
great again. The whole idea was not to
get involved in foreign wars, not to get
be what's it called? strong armed into
doing the bidding for foreign entities
and he's pretty much destroyed all the
tenants of the MAGA
uh rule book and obviously he's getting
a lot of heat and attack from his people
such as you know Nick Fuentes and etc
etc even Taka Carlson had certain
criticism of him so this will in his
eyes will allow him to bring back those
nationalists and this white nationalist
so is a good move for him.
>> He was saying that Somalia stinks.
>> It's garbage.
>> It's barely a country. Now, you lived in
Somalia for a bit, haven't you?
>> Yeah, I was I was young, so I'm not
based on that. But
>> tell us about your
>> uh
>> What do you think of that of those
comments?
>> Well, you could say what you want. Has
he been there?
>> I don't think so. Yeah,
it's it's not even worth responding to
really in my opinion.
>> Why do you think he's using this kind of
porative language?
>> He needs to he needs for him to get the
approval rating that he was once he
needs to show himself to be the strong
man to be to really take a a divisive
position. So he
>> Why Somalia though?
>> Uh I would say it's number one for
example in England.
>> Yeah. It's it's funny how it works
because far right here in England their
focus has been main on the pakali
community.
>> Yeah.
>> So for there over there it's I think it
makes sense for them to focus on Somali
community for several reasons. Number
one color.
>> Yeah.
>> It's very easy to identify black.
>> Second religion,
>> Islam. So it ticks all the boxes
required to get the the white
nationalists going together. is a very
tax. It's
>> not like a state that a Gulf state that
is strategic relation.
>> Yeah. No, it's not.
>> But even if it was, he probably wouldn't
care either, would he?
>> I think he would care since they're
paying him very well. He would care. He
he cares about his pockets very much. He
does. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. He's pardoning
people left, right, center, criminals,
you name it. So he's he's he cares a lot
about money. He he's driven he's driven
by money.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. So it makes sense. Well, he's not
going to be using that money for long
cuz he's what, eight years old now,
right?
>> Yeah. Yeah. His age, but he doesn't look
>> he's he's like these are these are his
last years
>> and he's ch he's choosing to attack
communities and stuff like that.
>> Yeah. Well, one foot in the grave, but
reality is he's still money hungry. He's
still subservient to certain entities
which people know about and certain
lobbies. So, the guy doesn't have much
integrity or dignity. So, I don't think
people need to worry too much about it.
>> These days are numbered anyway.
>> Absolutely. Now, this green sauce is
hot. Yeah. As you can see, I'm sweating.
Yeah.
>> But it's exciting. Now, some You don't
like it? Or you don't have it?
>> Uh, no. I like it, but I can't tolerate
it. It's It's hot, but it's exciting.
>> It's It's like a power punch.
>> Yeah. It's uh
It's It's It's chili.
This what this is is why it's
interesting is the following.
>> You've got the cards. It's got European
influence because this is at the time
obviously I think Italy obviously past
>> there's a pasta and all that stuff when
they colonized. Um so it's got the
European influence but it's still very
much an African dish. It's got the Arab
influence as well. The Yemen influence
would you say that?
>> Absolutely. Yeah.
>> Yeah. There's definitely overlapping
culture between the Yemen the Yemenes
and Somalis also in terms of proximity.
>> Makes sense. Yeah. How do someone
selfidentify?
Would you identify more with the black
community generally or as a a separate
entity like Turks or how would you how
do you react?
>> On a personal level I stuff I identify
with the Chinese community.
>> Yes.
>> On a personal level.
>> Yeah.
>> But obviously I can't speak for som are
quite diverse. Some might identify with
the black community, others with Arabs.
as as you know Sam is part of the Arab
League. So he's a so it's a difficult
question for someone to answer. I'm not
al also I'm not speaking on behalf of
Somal. I'm speaking for myself. That's
it.
>> Okay. Be very political about the answer
to this question.
>> No, I'm being quite honest and frank.
>> It's it's it's difficult. So this man is
trying to attack our Muslim Somali
community.
>> Absolutely.
>> What what's our message to this man
that's trying to attack our Somali
community here?
uh zindidar more insults
>> because actually it's given us publicity
isn't it?
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's true.
>> Any helping us
>> what's the phrase any
>> publicity? It's good publicity.
>> Yeah. Good propaganda some Yeah. Yeah.
So
>> now people are going to realize why is
it why is he singling out these people?
What are the who are these people?
>> To be fair I've heard I've not watched
it yet but I have heard certain
commentators if you can call them that
such as Fuentes trying to identify the
motives behind his moves. all political
all to try to show himself to be that
nationalist that that savior that he
once proclaimed to be that strong man
once he once sold people he sold himself
to be reality is a food
I've eaten I've beat him so I'm going to
eat after I'm going to eat after the
whole federation by myself
>> it's called federation eh
>> I think so
>> federation is the camera agree
>> cuz usually sometime I go to a Somali
restaurant you know what I say
>> give me the intercontinental
Give me the international.
>> Seriously,
>> I forget the name of the theition. They
say Union Federation. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, I think that
>> So, what's your position? How you
>> Yeah.
>> What do you think? Why do you think he's
doing? What's his motive?
>> I don't care.
You know, Trump is a showman.
Like, I think that, you know, he's he
doesn't care about any particular. He
just thinks that I'm going to throw this
community under the bus to energize the
base.
>> There you go. And I think what it is is
that he probably looks at Minnesota.
>> He speaks to people that are online all
the time from my understanding and
they're telling him, "Look, you got
these Somalis in the country just like
the Europeans have it.
>> So do something about or say something
about it." So this is his way of he's
anti-immigration in a way. Yeah. So he
he's trying to rally that base.
>> His approval rating is dwindling.
>> He's not entirely anti-immigration. His
issue he's completely fine with having
white South Africans coming in. No
issues with that.
>> Oh yes.
>> Yeah. It's not anti-immigration. It's a
particular type of immigration. Yeah.
>> He He doesn't mind. He's bringing racism
back in fashion.
>> Yeah.
>> But
he's nothing.
>> Yeah. There's a Trump. He's going to be
finished soon. Absolutely. And you know,
>> I don't know of any American food that's
anywhere close to as diverse and
as tasty as this.
>> No, burger. Burgers are good sometimes.
>> Yeah, but burgers shouldn't be
attributed to the American culture,
shouldn't it?
>> Yeah.
>> Maybe it comes from what? Hamburg.
Hamburg is is Germany, is it?
>> Yes. Yes.
>> Is that right?
>> Yeah.
>> So, what what is the American food that
you're talking about that you
>> Hot dogs?
>> Hot dog.
>> Hot dogs. I don't know.
>> Hot dog. I don't know.
They they they're it's a 300-y old
nation, you know, Habashan
and uh Somalis, would they trace that?
Would you would you associate yourself
with Habash ancient Habashan?
>> I'm not
>> uh potentially. I'm not good at history.
It's potentially. Yeah,
>> it's a very long-standing civilization.
You know, America's been around for 200
years
bullying people, killing people. had 11
wars in their history. All this kind of
stuff is not in a position to talk about
what country this and what country that
the indigenous of that land were natives
anyway. You've got nothing to uh be so
proud about anyway, you know. And you
know Trump, he's he is his granddad
that's German.
>> I don't know much about
>> someone's German. His granddad.
>> What camera is his granddad?
>> Maybe he's connected to Hitler.
>> He's connected to Hitler. That's why
he's so fascistic. Maybe he's got the
the the blood of Adolf in his veins.
>> So, you know, you have this kind of
European critiques come from the far
right or from the right or from the alt
right or whatever. And they talk about
like how weak the um Muslim nations are,
African nations, Middle Eastern nations.
It might seem like it's a what do you
call it? A reductionist analysis.
But for me
the main reason this is the case
is due to colonialism.
Okay, this is my analysis. Look, think
about it. Yeah. What is in common
between subsahara and Africa on the one
hand? Yeah. And
Latin America,
parts of Asia. It's all the colonial
legacy. It can't be our religious
explanations. can't be this, can't be
that country, whatever. So when they
say, "Oh, your countries are like that."
It's because they've made it like that
in a way.
>> So you were saying something about that.
>> No, but what I was getting at is just
it's a product of colonization, which is
a lot of these nations, take any African
nation, West African nation for example,
after colonization,
can we say they're sovereign country?
You have foreign entities going there
taking their minerals, taking their
gold, taking all their wealth for next
to nothing. Zero. Zero.
>> Why? Because they have a puppet
>> in power who's given minimum wage in
terms of corruption.
>> Yeah.
>> And he's role is to subdue
>> the society. So they would live in
poverty
>> and these westerners or foreign entities
will benefit for them. You can even, it
doesn't have to be even westerners. Look
at what's happening in Sudan.
>> Yeah.
>> Look what's happening in Sudan. They
want Sudan to live in poverty. So
certain Arab countries
>> can get their wealth and the gold and
whatnot for free for nothing to next to
nothing.
>> And they will sell that what they've
stolen essentially on the market and
earn ridiculous amount of money. The
reality is not these countries are not
sovereign.
>> They appear to be sovereign. They had
the illusion of sovereignty, but it is a
corrupt state led by a puppet whose
allegiance is to the dollar. And that's
it. And they will remain that way until
they have real sovereignty. That's the
reality. That's true. And now I just
want to look I mean the reason why we're
in the stage that we're in now as
Muslims I don't tell me to what extent
you accept or agree or disagree but
there a lot of reason why we are in the
stage that we're in is simply because of
the leaving off jihad
>> actually in the sense that
when we started disuniting
fighting within ourselves tribalism
nationalism,
>> the Turks and the Arabs, Arabs versus
the Turks, the Ottoman Empire and all
that stuff. It led to the collapse and
then this is what we're seeing now. And
that's why I'm saying that we this is a
point for us to kind of come together.
We see like for example, we find it's
people from different countries or like
this whole rift between Somalia land and
Somalia and all this kind of stuff.
It actually lends itself to foreign
occupation. It makes it easier to buy
the conquer, doesn't it?
>> Yeah, divide conquer. I agree with that.
But I think just relegating the whole
all these series of issues to one issue,
it might be too simplistic in my
opinion. There has to be a nuance.
Economy has a huge role to play.
>> Economy.
>> Economy has a huge role to play.
>> Education has a huge role.
>> Having control of your borders. Fun
enough sound like Trump
having control of your borders
>> also plays a big role. The reality is
>> after globalization
>> Somali Trump.
>> Yeah. Somali Trump.
>> I just need a hand. But reality is
>> with globalization the world is not what
it used to be.
>> Before you need in order to control
foreign countries you needed boots on
the ground. Yeah,
>> but here
>> you have other vessels
>> that will do the job for you in order to
take the resources while you are the
comfort of your of your what do you call
it home call it trading call it IMF
whatever you want to whatever name it's
put on it is essentially exploiting and
taking the resources of the poor keeping
them poor and you get rich up and you
develop what your education you develop
your army you develop all these these uh
what's it called their assets
to maintain power. These guys can never
get power until they're sovereign until
they have like let's take Ibrahim for
example
>> why is there so assassination he's
basically one of these leader of West
African country
all he tries to do is ensure that the
resources of his country belong to the
country so they can pay off their debt
etc etc agree that the French want him
out he has to now seek allegiance
>> this is a very this is a very poignant
point
>> yeah he has to seek allegiance with
Russia, you can't. But right now, hey,
what the what did the the Belgians do to
what is his name? In the 1950s,
>> a leader came and said, you know what,
we need our country to be
>> they won't let them be independent. They
understand the reputation of course.
>> This is this is why this guy Trump is
coming out with all this stuff now,
isn't it? It's just part of the same
playbook
>> because the lot lot of critics, a lot of
analysts are saying this is the the end
point or the emp the American empire is
coming to it the plateau and it's coming
to to its end and usually a sign of a
decline empire is erratic. Blame this,
attack this, start waring this. They
they don't act rationally.
>> It's insecure behavior
>> of course because now it's
>> oh look at look at this nation. Yeah.
the right you see the rise of China I
don't know if you remember during co
>> I mean you couldn't imagine like the
Chinese president
>> saying something about Somalia like this
it would be just so beneath him
>> yeah it just it just
>> be so beneath him to do that
>> it's not if you go back to co time what
did Trump call he's called the Chinese
virus
the virus from China was just attack
attack attack make it racial yeah it's
definitely secure
>> so that so Trump is a caricature
and a personification
>> for the uh civilization of the west
that's in in steady decline
>> frantic insecure fragile
>> uh cartoonized image of of of western
civilization
>> also even the type of leaders the
especially if you look at American
leaders say 20 years ago before 20 years
ago
>> they had certain conduct forum it's part
and parcel
Now you get characters like Trump and we
had Boris here.
>> Yeah, exactly. Buffoon.
>> Yeah, buffoon. It's shocking such
characters that was said about him. Do
you remember someone said to him um
uh famous quotation someone came to him
and said that well beneath the buffoon
we know that you've got a shrewd
politician and then and then and Boris
respond. said before I think you'll find
that we know the buffoon is as a
buffoon.
>> He's right on that. But that's my my
point. So you got these sort of leaders
that are almost clown life.
>> Yeah.
>> And they got popular support but people
are hanging on to uh the ideas of
nationalism, the ideas of power, but
they're hanging on to it, clinging on to
it. And unfortunately for them
absolutely is fading. This is the
decline of of the American empire. The
days of one one rule, one control over
the whole world. With the rise of China
and especially the Chinese and Russian
rel relationship, things are changing
politically. So now the Americans,
especially Trump is is erratic. I don't
know if you you following closely, he's
been claiming to ending to have ended so
many wars, wars that never existed
between countries that knew each other.
>> Well, he doesn't know these countries.
Did you see him when he was in African
at the summit or something like that?
Yeah.
>> And he was like, I didn't even know
about this. Recently he was talking
about Sudan
>> and they say, "Oh, Sudan, I didn't know
anything about Sudan and you know, I was
just told about Sudan and I didn't know
anything about Sudan." I'm surprised he
even knew that Somalia was a country.
>> He was told about it.
>> He doesn't know anything.
>> He was told about, but I heard him
speak.
>> Honestly, he is probably one of the
lowest IQ presidents any country's ever
had for a very long time. Possible he
has very limited general knowledge like
for a president
>> possible because not too long ago a
couple few months ago he said oh I met
the Somali president did you know Sman
had a president and he said I spoke I
spoke to about Omar can take her back
and and he said no we don't want her
something something along those lines
you guys it's comical at best
>> yes so
>> it's sign of decline and insecurity
>> that's a very that's a very interesting
and very important point that you know
you don't speak like that about other
nations Unless you felt really insecure
about your own.
>> Yeah, he he's aware of it. That's why
even with his tariffs, he came he came
into power and overnight he's got these
miraculous tariffs and somehow he's
going to make America great again. Has
he made America great again? Has he
improved the economy? Will it improve
the economy? Most economists I've
listened to, they think it's a joke. He
say this guy doesn't have the sign of
any sort of economy. And the reality is
with the next 5 years we will see the
proof will be the pudding will
be a great pudding I see. Ask me your